ein neuer blick auf die alten meister
die ausstellung giganten der renaissance
zeigt die bekanntesten werke von raffael
michelangelo und leonardo da vinci
digitalisiert animiert und mit musik
unterlegt
dass kunst kraftwerk leipzig arbeitet
bei dem projekt mit dem italiener
gianfranco ja nun zieht zusammen ein
weltweit bekannter videokünstler
die asymmetrisch studium
die renaissance war damals sehr modern
und hat die welt der kunst verjüngt und
verändert sie bewegte sich weg von den
religiösen motiven hin zu immer mehr
weltlichen darstellungen und so konnte
auch die fresken malerei in die
architektur einfließen dass wir sonst
nicht möglich gewesen
unsere installation ist eine hommage an
diese große bewegung der kunst
um die multimedia show einem breiten
publikum zugänglich zu machen bedient er
sich der immersiven kunst
dabei taucht der betrachter mittels 24
prima in die acht meter hohen
videoprojektionen 1
so werden selbst die kleinsten
pinselstriche sichtbar
[Musik]
ich denke dass das zusammenspiel von
video und klang jetzt noch etwas neues
ist so wie es die fotografie und das
kino auch mal war auch sie haben sich
weiterentwickelt und unsere wahrnehmung
verändert sie ist nun nicht mehr nur
visuell sondern virtuell und auditiv von
beginn an spielt auch die musik eine
zentrale rolle
der sound künstler luca lombardi wählt
die stücke aus und arrangiert sie neu
[Musik]
ich arbeite besonders viel digital also
am computer aber ich arbeite auch mit
musikern zusammen die live spielen so
gibt es in der ausstellung ein stück von
mir dass ich ursprünglich für ein
orchester geschrieben habe
für die installation aber spielen nur
ein einziges streichquartett und ein
digitales orchester zu sein
am ende hört es sich an als ob ein
echtes orchester live in einer kirche
spielt die renaissance im 15 und 16
jahrhundert war eine bahnbrechende
epoche bis heute hat sie den blick des
menschen auf sich und die welt
nachhaltig verändert dazu haben auch die
werke von raffael michelangelo und
besonders leonardo da vinci beigetragen
er gilt als einer der berühmtesten
universalgelehrten aller zeiten
so war immer ein visionär der dinge
voraus die einige jahre nach ihm
erfunden wurden
ich denke wenn er in der heutigen zeit
leben würde hätte er bestimmt viele
erfindungen digital entworfen
vielleicht hätte in diesem raum ein
neues holografische fluggerät polizei
uraufgeführt wurde die ausstellung in
frankreich
das ambiente wurde für eine abgestimmte
bin ich zu tränen gerührt und mich hat
es wirklich ergriffen
das ist auch die absicht dieser künstler
sie wollen nicht mehr dass man sich
einfach nur so das gemälde anschaut
sondern eine andere art der begegnung
herstellten das ist was mich angeht
gelungen ich bin begeistert immersiven
kunst als kollektive erfahrung noch bis
ende 2019 können besucher in die welt
bekannten kunstwerke eintauchen
[Musik]